sykes ça règle sa règle serait qu'à le
regarder quand on parle aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on sait ça vous le voyez pas
l'âge en train de fermer tout de suite
c'est avec le sony xperia pro x est un
smartphone un peu particulier parce
qu'il est un capteur de 1 pouce du coup
ça permet d'aller chercher plus de
choses plus de détails je fais plus de
lumière alors aujourd'hui l'idée n'est
pas de faire un test de ce smartphone
parce que c'est pas parce que je vais
venir chercher ou non pas le tester sur
la photo sur la vidéo moi je pose une
question c'est quand sony m'a proposée
tient est ce que tu as envie monsieur
retester le sony xperia pro y je me suis
alors je m'assois où la lumière je me
suis dit hé ben écoute et pourquoi pas
parce qu'en fait j'ai toujours en train
de regarder ce qui se passe du côté des
caméras en me disant est-ce qu'il va y
avoir une nouvelle caméra intéressante
est ce que c'est une solution que moi je
peux me dire utiliser ce que du coup si
une solution peut venir commander
d'autres personnes qui souhaitent
utiliser une caméra je dirais avec un
gros capteur de 1 pouces professionnels
avec des guillemets s'est pas réellement
du coup parce qu'on est quand même sur
un smartphone mais est ce que pour
autant c'est une solution intéressante
on sait vraiment ce qu'on veut se poser
comme question aujourd'hui à l'agencé
tap vous le voyez pas j'emprunte film
avec ma caméra arrière devant et bien
j'ai un moniteur dans lequel je me vois
la coucou je me vois j'ai en dessous une
petite poignée je vous le montrer dans
quelques instants va se poser au studio
que je peux venir zoomer dans l'image
voyez comme ça directement grâce à un
petit panier enfin c'est comme une
petite télécommande comme un oslo de dj
am je peux venir changer d'objectif
pendant que je vous parle pas la presse
je parle c'est un peu relou je peux le
faire uniquement lorsque j'arrête donc
la veille sur le capteur principal lâche
pas sur un tel objectif sera positionné
sur 12 mégapixels de tous les côtés
alors c'est les équivalences h et sonia
saga soit 1,24 à 57 ans 16 donc la
chaudière mais nous ou mais un petit peu
numériquement et coucou salut toi salut
toi comment ça va donc ça ok je le fais
comme ça je passe sur l' ultra
grand-angle en mode de aulas a lu pigeon
camp ultra grand-angle en mode en mode
blog alors pour autant 5 c'est pas mal
je peux bien me rapprocher là je crois
qu'on n'a pas le stade c'est ce que
j'avais vérifié tout à l'heure mais
l'idée est intéressante voyez je le
prends comme ça je me dis je vais venir
bloguer je vais me balader alors là je
suis précise parce qu'il ya un peu de
lumière bourdin interfax au jardin lecoq
à clermont ferrand pour ceux qui connaît
très parlant des zones d'ombré donc
voilà l'idée c'est de se dire je viens
vous loguez je vais me balader comme ça
est ce que la solution est pertinente ou
pas donc on regarde ça leur dit le match
suite vous en commentaire est ce que ça
peut vous intéresser une solution avec
un gros capteur de pouce à ses pas sur
le 1 pouces laisse pas que j'ai un
triptyque de 12 mégapixels 12 sur le
grand temps où seuls trois cantons et 12
sur le téléobjectif je repasse sur le
capteur principal là je sens quatre
principales sa loge de capter plus de
lumière mon loyer la lumière en demande
en plein jour elle en fait ça fait le
taf voilà un peu l'idée de base voilà la
promesse qu'ils aient fait tout ça
change et une caméra de celles filmées
du coup grâce à mon mobile mais caméra
de ses filles je m'en fous j'en ai plus
plus du tout l'utilité je suis petit et
d'une solution mobile pour venir bloquer
avec l'aspirateur qui coûte quand même
je vous le dis rien que ça 1800 euros le
smartphone sans compter le moniteur sans
compter le petit outillage et ont plus
en dessous dont j'ai mangé le nom 1800
euros et sans compter le fait soit d'y
rajouter un petit micro externe chose
que je n'ai pas fait ici mais lui
sourire on s'est quand même paris
[Musique]
regardez le clip de blogging c'est ça
c'est celui-là c'est ce que vous avez
ici alors je vous montre comment ça se
décompose vous avez effectivement
attendre et commencer par là lui mais si
on allume pas comment ça n'a pas
fonctionné ça s'allume là comme ça alors
là regardez je vous fait vous voyez
coucou toi comment ça va on utilise ici
votre capteur principal on va tout
donner dans quelques instants et
regardez vous le voyez ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'en fait ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que là je suis en
train de me filmer et c'est aimante et
donc un côté pratique ça se pose c'est
aimante et c'est vachement bien donc ce
système je trouve plutôt intéressant
parce que j'ai des petits boutons sur le
devant qui nous permette effectivement
devenir commander c'est à dire lorsque
je suis là par exemple sur mon capteur
principal m'a regardé hop là je viens je
joue mais dans l'image l'âge des zooms
là je prends une photo là je peux lancer
une vidéo mais pour lancer une vidéo ben
y'a un truc un peu relou c'est que là
dans mon logiciel regardez il faut que
je vienne dans la partie vidéo up la
fonction la partie vidéo est bien là je
peux dire déclencher une vidéo voilà ça
déclenche une vidéo donc là ça marche
c'est déjà plutôt rigolo ok là j'arrête
la vidéo mais je préfère photos pour
faire une photo vaut genre tombe de
l'autre côté et puis ensuite là j'ai un
petit bouton c1 qui permet de changer
d'objectif j'appuie l'aop là je passe
sur mon 50 mm j'appuie là je passe sur
mon 16 mm et je m'appuie là je passe sur
mon 24 mm donc voyez c'est vachement mal
hein c'est assez intelligent c'est
pratique lorsque je vais me balader
comme ça alors ce système là je trouve
effectivement très pratique mais je
trouve un poids lourd un poil intentions
pas non plus dire attention c'est lourd
si je prends un boîtier ça va être
beaucoup plus lourd c'est un tout petit
peu lourd mais c'est intéressant alors
regardez je vous montre comment ça se
décompose en fait vous avez donc ici ce
moniteur soit le moniteur je peux venir
là lui mais je peux me dire l'éteindre
je pouvoir régler ici ma
nos idées hop là plus fort moins fort
les mre ce 39% de batterie est en fait
la batterie que vous voyez c'est la
batterie du smartphone parce que là on
va venir utiliser la batterie du
smartphone soit 39 sur 30 mètres sur le
smartphone puisque c'est lui qui lui
envoient du jeu et puis ensuite j'ai
petit bouton flip qui me permet de
changer de le mettre sur le haut sur le
bas en fonction de ce que je sois effet
miroir haut et bas donc il ya un côté
qui aussi assez sympa en fonction de ce
qu'on veut venir faire donc ça c'est
cool je vois que sur le côté je vais
avoir quoi mon input où je me rends chez
mon moniteur un petit bouton power je
peux venir ici branché plug in power
convenir à faire rentrer un petit micro
ici si je le souhaite ok donc ça c'est
cette première partie donc je vais vous
l'enlevez histoire de vous montrer la
suite donc ça voyez c'est mon moniteur
il est monté il vient là c'est assez
marrant ensuite je vais avoir mon
smartphone en lui-même qui est là donc
bon ça vous connaissez c'est un
smartphone est ensuite j'essaie de
partir à qui permet de venir bloguer
alors là je suis sur un petit pas de
vices voyez je peux le faire pivoter
dans un sens et dans l'autre camp le
mettre dans le sens où je veux donc je
vais avoir cet élément-là qui permet de
mettre mon smartphone ça s'étire ça se
referme c'est vachement pratique et
surtout les cellules qui aimante et en
fait à pour venir faire tenir le
moniteur dessus donc à ses matches de
poule et puis ensuite j'ai cette espèce
de deux poignées de grippe qui me permet
de venir tout piloté avec comme je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure quelques
boutons photos vidéos ou zoomer dézoomer
changer d'objectif et là hop là je viens
l'éteindre après je vais également avoir
un truc un peu malin c'est un petit
bouton sur le côté qui me permet de
venir changer mon angle et après ça le
bloc c'est un peu dur donc un côté revu
ça c'est sympa et ensuite je peux bien
l'ouvrir ici pour le poser en mode très
piégeux le poste en mode trépied ensuite
julien incliné ça comme je veux il fait
je peux y mettre sur une table et je
peux venir bloquer comme ça donc le truc
est plutôt plutôt rigolo tout en sachant
qu'ici vous venez lui vous lui mettez
une petite pile à l'intérieur des actifs
qu'ils s'équipent île plate plus qu'elle
est la référence de cette pile mais bon
c'est un celle là que vous avez là ça
c'est aussi un très très grand classique
c'est une serre 2032 comme ça vous savez
tout donc voyez le truc qui est bien ça
ça se connecte en bluetooth directement
à votre smartphone donc ça c'est très
très cool que vous dire sur cette partie
du dessus est bien là je peux venir à
brancher un tout petit micro externe si
je veux sûr d'améliorer la qualité du
son parce que mark von même s'il est
cool ça reste un smartphone et comme on
fait un truc un peu pas promet semi pros
comme blogging facile on peut le faire
donc l'idée bien cette modularité on
peut l'utiliser facilement mais plein de
choses dessus tout ça vachement
vachement cool après lorsque vous
l'utilisez pas mais il faut quand même
venir le protège et l'orangé il ya
plusieurs petits éléments donc il faut
quand même penser à ça donc pourquoi pas
après je donne le prix fort comme ça on
est aussi très très très cher le
smartphone en lui-même l'ex paria promis
lui il coûte quasiment 1800 euros
1799 euros on a un capteur de 1 pouces
il ya de la techno 1 5188 mais je vous
dirai dans quelques instants la partie
moniteur c'est à dire le câble ça et le
moniteur ça coûte combien ça ça en est à
on est à 199 euros 99 c'est aussi un
petit prix et puis vous avez alors ça
ils l'appellent comment la poignée ca
gpv péter de bt il adore les noms un peu
zarbi chez sony et donc nous ont bien
non un petit peu zarbi c'est la
référence 169 en 99 ce qui fait que le
trio regard des smartphones plus poignée
plus écran vous êtes un roulement de
tambour 2168 euros 81 18 c'est cher
c'est le prix d'un g h 6 9 avec le
bundle avec l'objectif c'est le leica le
12 60 il vous à 20 g h i avec donc voyez
compris danger à chier c'est dans vous
avez cette solution mobile qui le
logging qui est cool qui est
intéressante avec un bon capteur mais ça
coûte extrêmement cher alors c'est un
truc si vous avez dans cette vidéo je
vous parlais de sourire à sony c'est
bien ce qu'ils font sur les smartphones
c'est intéressant mais ils sont pas
d'aller du pôle thank you c'est à dire
on prend un smartphone et on fait une
photo et c'est un peu ce que je reste
souvent reproché aux maisons ont fait
les choses différemment je trouve ça
bien en fait que sony fasse des choses
différemment parce que ismet papa ça
tout le monde ils ont leur parti-pris
ils ont leur façon de voir les choses et
je trouve ça extrêmement bien ça ça me
plaît énormément maintenant lorsqu'on va
sur un smartphone grand public et ce qui
n'est pas le cas ici à ces passants
grand public on veut un truc on prend
prend une photo et ça marche ok et je me
dis toujours c'est un peu compliqué il
ya plusieurs applications pour la vidéo
c'est pas simple pourront bien qu'il
soit quand même je dirais améliorée ont
fait des efforts c'est quand même pas
extrêmement simple là avec ce smartphone
on veut pas du pôle télé chaumeton veut
pas un truc facile on veut pouvoir aller
un peu plus loin et je trouve qu'en
allant un peu plus loin pour le coup on
est vraiment loin et des foisons s'ils
n'ont pas un peu trop loin oui les
choses qui sont pas pratiques dire le
nec monsieur bruce et parce qu'il veut
il va un truc potential toqués il a
parlé d'un truc plus complet il là mais
il est pas content si je suis content je
suis content mais il ya des choses qui
me plaisent pas trop alors je vous
explique regardez neymar le smartphone
en lui-même vous allez comprendre je
vous montre vous avez pas moins de trois
applications une application ici qui met
votre application principal pour faire
là taux de la vidéo un peu classique
comme on l'a sur un smartphone mais vous
avez également une application cinéma
pro on connaissait déjà avant sur
d'autres smartphones notamment les
xperia one et puis vous avez vidéo pro
alors je dirai quand je vois ça je me
dis ok cinéma pro vidéo pro donc là je
fais de la vidéo mais c'est pas du
cinéma là je fais le cinéma mais pas la
vidéo mais c'est de la vidéo mais c'est
pas du cinéma déjà ça mon brouillon type
bon mais il aime bien brouiller un peu
les quarts alors oui je vous ai pas un
style plein de trucs parce que moi j'ai
vraiment m'intéresser sur la partie
vidéo et sur les usages vidéo alors ok
déjà applications principales étapes lit
je trouve intéressante pourquoi c'est
une à prix très classique en fait que
vous allez avoir de smartphones où vous
venez choisir je dirais votre votre
objectif alors vous savez chez sony ne
disent pas x 1 x 2 x 06 ils disent 24 mm
50 mm 16 mm en termes d'équivalent ce
parce que on se base sur la photo et
l'expérience photographique donc c'est
vraiment l'idée sauf que là ils ont pris
un petit peu les codes fois un x 2,1 ou
changent d'objectif fois 07 donc il ya
des repères et ça c'est cool on peut
changer d'objectif ici en bas ça aussi
c'est pratique et puis un autre truc qui
est intéressant à savoir c'est que vous
regardez vous êtes enfin et là vous avez
f 2.0 et vous appuyez là vous passez en
f 2.4 racines techno qui est vraiment
génial lathus à dire qu'en fait voyez
votre capteur la f 2.0 f4 s'est déjà dit
alain f 2.0 f4 donc là j'ai un
obturateur en fait qui va être je veux
dire manuel quelque sorte que je peux
venir modifier directement sur mon
capteur de 1 pouces laisser passer plus
ou moins de lumière donc ça c'est une
techno qui est vachement intéressante et
ça on le retrouve ici donc là c'est
vachement bien donc en termes de
software en terme de hardware ou un truc
qu'il vachement cool qu'est ce que je
peux bien vous montrer qui est
intéressant et ben on peut venir
travailler aussi au niveau du boc est un
peu plus de blocs un peu moins de
beaucaire capteur de 1 pouces occupé
faire venir faire des choses là dessus
ça c'est plutôt bien là je suis en
partie photo mais je peux mettre en
partie vidéo je peux venir
activer/désactiver mon âge dr une fois
de plus peut venir changer également ici
si je retrouve un peu cependant que je
peux faire sur un boîtier savoir le mode
basic les modes automatiques et puis
ensuite joueurs différents modes du mode
manuel de mode speed et compagnie ou là
je pouvoir venir gratter un peu plus
tels que je peux le faire un peu dans un
boîtier donc c'est l'idée de ce qu'on
peut venir retrouver ici voyez je vais
régler mes expos g1 régler mon auto
focus même balance des blancs jpeg ou
raw sur la photo ce que je peux foot et
en rond sans doute réussi donc il ya
beaucoup de choses intéressantes et
cette appli la dèche à elle est très
complète et elle me permet voyez d'aller
faire pas mal de choses automatique aux
basiques basics et l'application de
smartphones et automatique on arrive une
application de photos un peu plus tard
comme sur un boîtier donc là déjà assez
complet donc ça c'est cool pour quelque
chose à faire de la photo et de la vidéo
il faut savoir un truc c'est que cette
petite télécommande là on va l'appeler
la poignée parce que le gpv péter truc
mais un bon bref n'ont donc la petite
poignée mais fonctionne qu'avec cette
application là il ya un autre truc est
un poil rôle oui si je vous dis une fois
de plus si je voulais montrer c'est que
lorsque vous les switch et de la photo
et de la vidéo vous pouvez pas venir le
faire ici un appui sur le bouton photo
et vidéo ça marche pas je vais forcément
venir tourner votre smartphone depuis
donc un truc un peu un point leur louer
je pense qu'il faudra aller un peu plus
loin là dessus mais après ils nous ont
pondu deux autres applications alors on
se dirait qui peut le plus peut le moins
ok mais des fois ça en brouille un peu
alors j'ai cinéma pro cinéma pro on
connaissait déjà un plat je sais ça peut
chauffer on connaissait déjà au niveau
des experts y avoir un ex-paria 5
j'avais déjà montré cette application
cette application intéressante parce que
ben vous permet de choisir votre nombre
d'image par seconde à l'errance morts 25
images par seconde votre résolution 4k
ok why not sensation questionné sur un
ratio 21/9 donc ça sera forcément pas
plus allongée donc des images par
seconde - d'ouverture mon objectif
auquel 24 mm votre balance des blancs
votre réseau votre obturateur mise au
point manuelle et là vous avez des looks
alors les looks c'est aussi marrant
alors les où ça donne quoi en face ils
ne savent à colorer un peu votre image
je vais essayer de vous le montrer comme
ça le lot qui va venir coloré un peu
l'image mais pour autant vous n'avez pas
de lot à dire que autant là ça vient
vous type est un peu l'image brouillée
monochrome d'où bien faire des
chercheuses par défaut et vos maîtres
venus c est ce donc ça c'est plutôt
rigolo si le fait de se dire ok je peux
venir choisir un petit peu une
colorimétrie mme tang d'image mais un
truc qui manque vaches parce que je suis
sur un smartphone plus à usage pro
semi-pro pas filmer en en log pas filmer
flat voyez je peux pas mettre de l'ordre
du coup dessus donc ça ça fonctionne pas
ses looks c'est rigolo mais je peux pas
aller assez loin donc il ya aussi un
côté frustrant que je vais avoir une
image plate pour spir travailler ma
colorimétrie pascal imaginons que moi je
suis en mode blog je le prends mes jeux
de venir mixer après qu'une partie
studio avec mon assiette s3 ou alors
avec un mode blog avec un plus gros
boîtier avec un jason toujours un truc
intéressant mais là je peux pas j'avais
oublié match va être beaucoup plus typé
même si je prends un truc de base et ben
je peux pas venir non retouchées comme
je le souhaiterais et mettre le dessus
donc tous à un poil relou donc voyez ça
c'est une des premières limites qu'on me
retrouver ici donc à prévoyez bon bah
c'est assez assez bien réfléchi quand
même hein j'ai un petit but mettre ici
je suis un chef j'ai mon collègue serge
235 bonjour la batterie qui me reste ma
mémoire ok donc voilà un peu l'idée donc
ça c'est assez rigolo mais il un peu
quelque chose là dessus c'est parti et
ensuite c'est l'application vidéo pro
alors là on se dit ok encore une de plus
et ben alors la vidéo pose encore autre
chose vidéo pro vous venez là aussi
choisir hop là vous passez du 24 mm vous
monter jusqu'à 72 heures après c'est
plus de la petite c'est du numérique et
à vous descendez jusqu'en quoi en ayant
24 parce qu'il faut le changer
d'objectif sinon auto focus manuel et là
je peux le nier enregistrer directement
alors voyez j'ai pas mal de petits
paramètres au niveau de maîtrise aux
limites des eaux je peux mettre une
limite haute je pense une limite basse
ok suivi d'objets activer désactiver si
en plus ça va bien détecter les hommes
et les animaux donc un tout qui aussi
plutôt pas mal moko des cas séduire 64
mètres le hb 265,6 joue aussi tac tac
tac
donc voyez il ya pas mal de petits trucs
qui sont quand même assez intéressant
étalonnage niveau donc là je peux mettre
un bon petit niveau me ferais un état
l'eau de mon niveau qu'est ce que je
peux venir vous montrer encore bon
tutoriel si l'itf et là de la même
manière je peux pas venir filmer en flat
et ça c'est un truc qui est un poil rôle
ou aussi parce que ça mériterait
vraiment bien filmé en flat alors je
veux pas dire que tous les smartphones
film en fait mais si vous regardez je
vous ai présenté le jour aux normes ajiq
4 prob 1er film relate alors attendez
j'ai pas bu résultat je sais pas si
c'est bien mais c'est du flat et ici pas
fini on flatte alors je vais voir un
suivi d'objets je vais rentrer à qui je
peux jouer sur mon bouquet je peux lire
régler plein de choses m'ont
d'obturateur la chevelure d'automatismes
et radio plan va se mettre comme ça je
peux venir qu'elle aimait iso je vais m
en 640 dans la pièce et a très bien la
balance des blancs je laissais en
automatique donc voyez on peut faire des
trucs qu'ils sont sympas donc tout ça je
trouve ça vachement cool mais on n'est
pas dans un tout pro voyez j'aurais aimé
qu'on aille encore un peu plus loin et
puis bien sûr pas pro c'est pas grave si
on va bloquer du smartphone à pardonner
un sucre forcément promets moi je trouve
que il nous perdre un peu quoi avec 3
appli est d'autant plus pour une fois de
plus la police ne peut pas utiliser avec
les deuxièmes prix là alors que ces
vidéos pro et cinéma pro je sais pas
peut-être qu'ils se sont dit on à déjà
cinéma promet on voudrait faire un autre
truc plus adapté donc en fait vidéo pro
et en fait on a un smartphone qui
devient un peu une usine à gaz cinéma
pro vie des impros je peux faire plein
de choses quoi donc l'idée de venir
bloquer avec je suis d'accord ok le
formage pour ça hyper canon la poignée
qui se transforme mon trépied l'idée
d'avoir un capteur de 1 pouces je trouve
ça aussi hyper hyper canon de venir
poser un petit moniteur qui vient
cémenté c'est juste génial al étoffe qui
soit relié en tapant dans la batterie de
mon smartphone aussi bien sûr je ne
m'empêche retard a demandé il est comme
ça si red shoes d'interoute je disais
juste que l'idée de pouvoir avoir un
petit moniteur qui vient taper dans la
batterie du smartphone pourquoi pas mais
l'autonomie ça va me descendre
relativement fortement voyez il ya un
truc qui est bien avec cette solution
parce que si vous voulez acheter un
smartphone à clavier ou 1800 euros qui
vous servira à jouer parce que vous êtes
très mince un dragon 1188 intérieur vous
à des 12 giga de ram vous avez 500 12
giga de stockage avec une cote de faire
plus pour l'augmenter jusqu'à 1 tera
donc le stockage et à la puissance et de
la performance elle est là vous avez un
triple capteur de 12 mégapixels avec
toutes les qualités qu'on va retrouver
ici en terme d'image mais je trouve
qu'ils ont encore un truc qui marche pas
parce que je suis à plus de 2100 euros
et ya plus de 2100 euros env logging et
je vois ici j'ai réfléchi dans un dans
un set up 2100 euros 2100 euros je peux
acheter une petite caméra sony qui peut
emmener un peu en mode poitan shoots
faciles même je pense choper un duvet
locke dessus à vérifier ça mais je suis
pas sûr je peux m'acheter un géant si
soulagée du vélo et des options dingue
mais on n'est pas dans l'idée du blog un
peu léger après c'est du blog avec un
boîtier un message l'a fait pendant
longtemps et ce serait génial mais je
sais pas je me dis est-ce que c'est pas
moi léger 2000 euros je vais pas me
trouver un gh5 peu moins cher et puis me
prendre un smartphone m'a beaucoup moins
chez envoyé à améliorer ce qui serait
déjà beaucoup quoi c'est pas rien
d'autre il ya un truc qui est génial il
montre des choses il montre un savoir
faire et montrer nos ambitions mais je
trouve ça encore aujourd'hui trop cher
peut-être les professionnels qui font de
la vidéo et utilise un boîtier sony
alpha et qu'ils veulent et bien leur
leur smartphone à côté de sensations
vous pouvez venir les relier tous les
deux faire n'importe quel autre
smartphone vous avez l'application moi
je le fais avec un iphone le pilote
directement mon boitier avec donc ça on
peut la voir je trouve ça bien bon après
je vous montre mais je trouve qu'il
manque des choses après vous avez un
processeur traitement d'image c'est le b
11 x si vous voulez shooter vous avez
des photos en rafale avec 20 images par
secondes vous avez bien évidemment du
format raw on peut shooter en rond sans
aucun problème des retouches et après
dans lightroom et envoyé ok mais moi je
vous demande pas de la photo parce que
c'est vraiment le jeu vidéo qui
m'intéresse vous avez en plus des petits
boutons dessus dont notamment un petit
bouton pour venir déclencheur il est
hyper canon parce que regarder le bouton
pour venir déclenché on le sent il ya un
côté un peu grippe sous le doigt donc
chaud ça vachement vachement cool ça
smartphones qui certifie ip65 ip68
pendant une batterie quatre mille cinq
cents millions perdre à l'intérieur même
si je pense que ça aurait été cool d'en
mettre un peu plus mais ça aurait
peut-être emmener un smartphone encore
un poil plus épais on est quand même à
plus de 200 grammes là dessus c'est pas
le plus léger du monde mais bon est-ce
bien à une fois qu'on a rajouté ça le
moniteur et touche peut être la solution
il commence on la sent un peu sombre à
moi c'est vrai que j'ai l'habitude de
bloguer je prends un gorillapod je
prends mon iphone et je pars voiliers et
des fois je mets un micro externe ces
pratiques là c'est pas mal mais bon et
puis j'ai surtout un très très joli
écran oled avoir une maîtrise vraiment
aussi sony là dessus ce travail c'est
une dalle de 6,5 pouces ratio 21/9 celle
oled tout rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
et puis j'ai le moteur x1 pour mobiles
donc autant vous dire que oui si j'ai un
produit qui est très beau fabriqués par
sony m'attend je trouve très cher trop
cher je trouve que c'est compliqué au
niveau des applications je trouve que
c'est un super produit pour venir
bloguer il est vraiment intéressant mais
moi je mettrais pas de 1100 euros pour
acheter un smartphone à 1800 euros avec
une poignée avec un petit moniteur
pourtant chauffe-eau l'idéal est hyper
canons de la petite poignée du moniteur
du smartphone de cette idée un peu tout
en oeuvre pour ça coule à 1200 euros je
suis d'accord je suis d'accord pour y
aller à 2100 euros il est évident que
j'y vais pas maintenant ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que sony arrive à theresa
un peu plus bas un peu moins cher
peut-être sur un un sony xperia one un
mark iv allez savoir ça pour être plutôt
bien réussi à réunir toutes ces
applications photos vidéos en un pour
qui un vrai usage le fait de filmer en v
rogue et quand on va sur un produire des
citations peu plus professionnel à ça
aurait vraiment un sens plus plus plus
et puis on aura tout cool quoi un mais
deux mille euros il est évident que non
c'est un sas beaucoup trop cher voilà
voilà ça y est vous savez tous je vous
ai tout expliqué enfin je donnerai mon
point de vue en tout cas sur cette
solution trois ans nombreux smartphones
moniteur petite poignée dont je n'ai pas
le nom avec un où on peut venir zoomer
dézoomer on peut faire des grands zoom
comme ça alors dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce que déjà vous êtes
blogueur est ce que c'est une solution
qui pourrait vous intéresser ce que ça
correspond à vos usages est ce que vous
seriez plus avoue d'un battage et donne
un smartphone que je peux venir utiliser
avec un petit moniteur pour
effectivement voir ce qui se passe est
ce que cette solution peut vous tentez
est ce que vous pourriez mettre ce prix
là parce que je vous le dis une fois de
plus un vous n'êtes pas quasiment sur le
prix de ce qu'on peut acheter avec un
jet à 6 même si on n'est pas chez sony
même si c'est un smartphone même si avec
un des fils ne peut pas passer un coup
de fil et qu'on peut pas installer des
jeux dessus ça reste aux smartphones
avec toutes ses qualités mais également
toutes ses limites et puis aussi ses
défauts donc voilà je trouve ça
intéressant mais personnellement ce
n'est pas une solution sur laquelle
j'irai je me dis que un smartphone aller
à 600 700 mille euros c'est déjà très
bien avec ce que j'ai capable de faire
aujourd'hui si on regarde du côté de
chez samsung ou ne serait ce que pour
citer que du côté de chez apple donc là
effectivement ce nizon un vrai savoir
faire une belle maîtrise ya un côté un
peu transverse avec les boîtiers sony
alpha je suis d'accord là dessus
néanmoins est ce que j'irai me prendre
un smartphone sony juste pour utiliser
en caméra de logging je suis pas encore
convaincu bien qu'ils aient trois
logiciels pour venir chuté bien qu'ils
aient plein de solutions bien qui est de
la puissance je trouve ça encore un peu
complexe aujourd'hui alors promis on
s'adresse aux professionnels n'a pas
tout un chacun même si la solution est
intéressante et pertinente même si je
vois qu'on va dans de la mobilité je
sais pas je sais pas je suis pas sûr on
va mourir c'est en tout cas on va
réfléchir et pour verra peut-être plus
tard c'est sympa intéressant mais moi
aujourd'hui ce que je fais c'est déjà
cette heure pourrait avoir un nas et s3
plus pour le studio je pense que je vais
retourner ces tests orange à chaque
freinage agissent pour tout ce qui va
être extérieur mode blog et compagnie
lorsque je suis en vélo en déplacement
et bien je prends un gorille à paul sur
lequel j'ai mon iphone avec un petit
micro sur le dessus les qualités très
bonne ça me suffit pour ce que j'ai à
faire je fais du web donc ça me va très
très bien est ce que pour autant j'avais
bien m'acheter un smartphone à 1800
euros avec tout ce qu'on a mis rajouter
dessus non je ne pense pas même si ce
qu'on fait il y perd canon sur mon
smartphone je vais mal envers je me vois
pas mais je sais que c'est en train de
filmer et ça me convient donc même si
cette solution n'est trouvée vachement
intéressante même si j'aime l'idée même
si je trouve que c'est cool que sony
avait dans l'idée de se dire ok pour une
solution de blogging à
professionnellement du cac asie avec une
super qualité c'est pas forcément
l'instruction qu'elle gérait donc je
sais pas vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez aux places que vous en pensez
vous et puis on rend le tout ça on
continue à parler bien évidemment du
smartphone et st pons pas dit je vous
embrasse pour les soins d'une voix très
vite ans
[Musique]